[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar controlling pharmaceutical
powders confidence with every breath
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by labconco
to learn more visit labconco.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
jordan henderson
product manager lab conco corporation
and david wassesha director of biosafety
and containment products labconco
corporation
jordan and david you may now begin your
presentation
thanks for the introduction
today we're going to spend some time
talking about different ways to control
pharmaceutical powders
in laboratory and production settings
jordan henderson and i will be talking
about
different types of enclosures different
ways to analyze risks and how you can
implement these processes and pieces of
equipment to have a safer more robust
powder containment protocol for your
laboratory
today we're going to talk about a couple
of key parts of assessing and
integrating any type of powder
containment device into your laboratory
practices
and we'll start with by looking at risks
of pharmaceutical patterns
characteristics and things that make
them hazardous to human health
we'll also spend some time categorizing
risks based on exposure limits talking
about oels and oeps
and later we'll talk about evaluating
containment technologies you know the
different types of enclosures and
isolators that are available
and also ways that you can become an
advocate for potent compound safety both
for your own practices and for your
laboratory and greater manufacturing
environment
pharmaceutical powders come in many
different formats and generally they're
referred to as
active pharmaceutical ingredients or
apis
that's the the part of the the drug
delivery
load that is actually the chemical of
interest that's a therapeutic
and that's usually uh paired together
with excipients and other
combinations of powders and particles to
make the whole product
apis before they're formed though a
final product are typically crushed
ground or milled along the way from
synthesis
into their final form and during
the process of creating these these
different types of
particulates there are risks involved
with manipulating and changing the
states of those those particulates
powders are are convenient for a lot of
medicinal reasons and one of those being
the the fine grinding produces a high
surface area
and a lot of
highly bio available particulate for
the human body to absorb and make use of
and that allows for the human body to
greatly reduce the amount of drug that
needs to be administered for a
therapeutic effect
also increases the potency of that drug
and so
with that comes some risks at times
when pharmaceutical powders are ground
one of the goals is to achieve a uniform
size which helps with that bio
availability and consistency for dosage
later on in the process
in r d settings it also promotes
consistent laboratory results by
avoiding things like clumps or or chunks
of samples that do not readily dissolve
or potentially don't uh get analyzed
properly due to those clumps
and uh all of these um api powders are
precursors to final forms so
a lot of research and even into
production sites powders are often
handled due to their uh you know their
flexibility and how they can be packaged
and stored and moved along from r d to
production
and eventually they will become
finalized drug products whether it be
you know pressed into a tablet
filled into a capsule
sometimes blended into creams or
ointments dissolved into injectable
drugs or even sometimes left in a powder
state
such as in a lyophilized vial
now in powder form
drugs propose pose a significant risk to
users because
of their small size and ability to
penetrate different parts of the body
that
lead to high risk areas so one of the
most risky spots that a user can be
exposed to powders is through the airway
that's because the human body is
actively pulling air into its body
and forcibly removing aerosols from the
environments around the human
in that sense you're exposing uh the
human body it's left unprotected
to apis in
surfaces like mucous membranes
uh exposed to the inner skin on the body
and down into the lungs
where drug absorption can be rapid with
high potency and high effect
other surfaces if left
exposed such as skin and eyes on the
exterior of the human body are also
subjects to exposure risks and
in doing so being exposed
users are potentially
going to reach a point where they can be
harmed by apis that they may be handling
especially if they're particularly
potent
drugs recently speaking of potency has
become quite a bit more
more potent which means that uh
pharmaceutical companies going to
achieve a standard where less is more
where a sick patient or someone seeking
a therapeutic effect
can take less of a drug get more of a
therapeutic impact
and as a result uh have less has less
foreign material going into the body and
this is really attractive because not
only does it
save costs and manufacturing because
less drug is needed to create the same
effect but for human health it's always
better to administer the least amount of
drug as possible
to preserve other persons of the body
should a drug have side effects or other
unwanted
uh characteristics a great example of
this would be something like an antibody
drug conjugate or adc
these are extremely potent drugs
typically where an antibody and a drug
are bound together
where little amount of a drug is
stitching a ride on an antibody to a
therapeutic
site of interest within a body and these
drugs are incredibly potent and
incredibly effective they avoid side
effects in many ways
but pose risks to those handling those
products along the way
another thing to consider with potency
and
active pharmaceutical ingredients is
that while in high volumes they can be
easy to see
the small granules and powders can
easily aerosolize and to a user with um
with normal vision it can it can be
quite difficult to see how the powders
may be dispersed in an area that they're
uh working in and in fact the users
uh with good 20 20 vision have a
difficulty seeing any kind of
concentration of powder in the air more
than 100 milligrams for i'm sorry less
than 100 milligrams per cubic meter in
the air
so as a result
oftentimes people can be working with
potent drugs that have an oel or
operational exposure limit well below
this value
and not know that they're being actively
exposed to those drugs
so as david previously mentioned that
occupation or exposure limits or oels
are really just classifications
and ways to assess certain levels of
risk when it comes to handling hazardous
or potent or highly potent powders
um again these oels are just basic
guidelines that really just ensure
workers that are
not exposed to hazardous levels of
whatever substance that they're
potentially using now oels consist of a
variety of parameters
some of those include permissible
exposure limits and that comes from osha
the recommended exposure limit that
comes from the nios niosh
indicative
limit values that's from the eu and then
the threshold limit values which comes
from the ac
gih as well
now really all of those
particular parameters
really are just
used for
incident level exposures one-time kind
of exposures to really hazardous powers
there's also
another parameter that when it pertains
to oels uh known as the time weighted
average uh and and that value consists
of the concentration of a hazardous uh
powder uh or something substance in the
air uh averaged over an eight eight hour
day during a 40-hour work week because
oftentimes these processes
being carried out with these hazardous
powders are done by real workers working
eight-hour shifts five days a week it's
important to really establish
really kind of any potential hazardous
exposure limit
in that context as well and not just a
single incident
in conjunction with oels
we have occupational
exposure bands or oeds as well
while oels are more or less
standardized
risk assessments for certain compounds
oeds
are going to be a mechanism that is used
to assign to those hazardous chemicals
or compounds
that kind of quantifies their toxicities
on a site-to-site basis
this is a simplified tool
that is used to classify that wide range
of apis
as previously mentioned within an
organization
and it's really kind of an integral part
of the
risk assessment and risk management
process
that is being carried out on a daily
basis
when handling hazardous apis or other
compounds
for the most part it generally follows
just a lettering or number system
oeb1 or oeba levels
gender b
i'm sorry
tend to be
less hazardous while going up all the
way to a potentially
oed level e or oeb level five which
would be the most hazardous
to
potential or workplace exposure
general guide guidance when it comes to
those bands again
they vary from organization to
organization and that's going to be
dependent on a variety of factors based
on kind of the engineering controls that
are set uh that are put in place uh for
that site to protect those workers from
potential exposures
uh and really kind of the components
that uh make up
um
kind of that oeb banding are going to be
uh
listed here so carcinogenicity um
reproductive toxicity uh genotoxicity um
kind of any uh organ toxicity even at
low i mean especially at low doses
uh and then uh drugs specifically that
mimic existing drugs and really what's
important about this is that
a drug that is structurally similar can
therefore have similar properties uh to
a known oeb or a known oel so we can
kind of have a really kind of just a a
good jumping off point to put in place
certain engineering measures to again
make sure workers are protected when
handling these substances
as jordan mentioned with oebs and oels
they're a great way to look at hard data
on oels
and then establish a general guidance
for an organization
but oels on their own and oebs on their
own are not enough to establish all
considerations that a laboratory needs
to implement when bringing a process
into their laboratory
the oel has established how much a
person can be exposed to
and oebs put that into a grouping but
there are processes that have an
inherent risks that go beyond
what might be expected to happen during
a normal day and and activities that
oftentimes happen with handling of apis
on the r d side involve tasks like
weighing both small and large volumes
milling actually grinding powders
whether to reduce chunks or to achieve a
consistency in the the size of
particulates in a sample
also tools like characterization so
using a malvern master sizer particle
sizing instruments
or assessing purity are also
manipulations that can take place in
powders
on the r d side those are all things
that can happen on very small scales you
know microgram scales to
kilo scale and it's important to
consider all of the risks that may
happen you know is my vessel
at risk for tipping over and overcoming
the engineering control i'm working
inside of
or
is it maybe just a small sample and
there's very low risk so those are
factors that need to go into the risk
assessment associated with an oeb and
toxicity referral compound
now on the manufacturing side
processes can go from very small lines
to very large volumes and at times
exceed 100 kilos
and in such a process it's really
important to look at the entire line of
work
materials transfers and other factors
that
exchange part particulates and potency
compounds where users can be exposed in
ways that may not be
most obvious when installing installing
the equipment used for manufacturing
the easiest way to assess a risk
quantify it and get a best level of
opinion is to consult an industrial
hygienist whether it's someone from
your company and your organization's ehs
department
or if it's an outside source
and uh this process is going to look at
you know if the oels are known
or not looking at similar drug data to
understand at least a baseline level of
potency
followed by potentially implementing
surrogate powder studies where you
actually replicate
the processes to be carried out in the
laboratory or manufacturing environment
by using a less potent
compound usually something that's
completely non-hazardous to users
like a sugar or an approximate sodium
now
once this is done those are factors that
can all go together to establish a
general oeb level
and that is a way to harmonize the
general level of safety or expectation
for
a
company on how they will handle a
certain process and a certain volume of
compound but it does not uh go without
saying that it's still critical for a
user to focus on daily activities that
present risks not necessarily
quantifiable by that risk assessment
process
so moving on to
ways to manage containment we understand
that there are ways to quantify the
potency of a drug and the way that users
can manipulate these workflows safely is
by using engineering controls that
generally are going to provide some kind
of negative pressure containment
now in this picture you see a
ventilated balance enclosure drawing air
away from the face opening that is a
visualization of smoke representing
negative pressure air flow from the
fronts to the back of the enclosure away
from the user
in these designs ventilated balance
enclosures or open systems are going to
use as low air flow as possible to avoid
turbulence which promotes
not only containment properties by
avoiding turbulent air and the mixing
and swirling of particulates and aerosol
eyes but it can also help with processes
that are sensitive such as weighing on
an analytical balance or a micro balance
engineering controls that are used for
powder containment also need to be
highly cleanable
many times these devices are used for
many different types of batches not only
of the same compound
of different weights but of different
types of compounds
sometimes hundreds or thousands of
compounds within one of these enclosures
over its lifetime so
being able to fully decontaminate the
the enclosure is critical to
its ability to work properly not only in
containment but also to avoid
cross-contamination sensitive samples of
materials that may be handled in the
enclosure
these designs of these enclosures also
combine airflow with hepa filtration so
that's high efficiency particulate air
filtration
and that particular that is being
generated in the powder form of an api
needs to be captured on some kind of
filter before the air flow going through
the enclosure is exhausted either back
into the environment of the laboratory
or out through the building
and these in these enclosures and
engineering controls are most commonly
found in two formats i mentioned the
ventilated balance enclosures which are
open systems as described in the image
here
but they also include a wide variety of
containment isolators that are sealed
systems which promote a
higher level of containment than even an
open system working with great efficient
containment airflow
so to piggyback on what dave was uh
explaining about a bag and bag out help
infiltration what this actually does is
this engineering control actually allows
for an additional complete barrier when
changing out those saturated hepa
filters from uh
potentially exposing not only the
workers but that environment that that
workers in uh to those hazardous apis or
powders
this is uh commonly found just in bio
containment labata but it should be
found throughout uh
really kind of the entire workflow that
these people are using uh these
hazardous powders or atis in
ideally
uh when it comes to pharmaceutical
these things are just ubiquitous
throughout the entire process so
definitely important there
now other engineering controls that are
commonly
used to really ensure user safety or
worker safety from potential exposures
are going to be ergonomics so ergonomics
is important because worker comfort is
insanely important to
preventing spills and
again increasing the risk of potential
exposures for those hazardous apis
also
it's important to validate containment
for any uh
vbes or isolators that are being used to
prevent
or provide that physical barrier uh
between that workflow and then then that
workflow that is handling that hazardous
api um as dave mentioned previously it's
generally with a a
a powder uh
for the most part sodium naproxen
naproxen is generally used to do this
you can also use lactose um and this can
be done uh either by a third party uh
consultant uh
we commonly use trinity it used to be
known as safe bridge to form these tests
in a third-party capacity but it's also
worth mentioning that
oftentimes we can these can be done
in-house just to reconfirm
containment of whatever piece of
equipment that you're implementing
to
achieve that engineering control
um also worth mentioning that when it
comes to those open-air
filtration systems uh ashrae 110 comes
in
sometimes
it's common practice to measure out a
small sample of a pharmaceutical api or
hazardous powder and then load them into
a chemical solvent so being able to
direct uh chemical vapors away from end
users is just as important as being able
to contain and direct uh
hazardous powder
away from the user as well
speaking of chemical vapors it's
important to recognize
a separation between
potent compound
containment vessels
and enclosures such as vbes and
isolators
and differentiate them from chemical
fuels
chemical humors are ubiquitous with all
chemistry laboratories
and widely found throughout
pharmaceutical environments
but they should never be used with any
kind of potent compound of any sort
and that is because they do primarily
because they do not contain any kind of
exhaust hepa or ultrafiltration to stop
particulates from being ejected outside
of the exhaust system
so
in most bbes and isolators a hepa filter
is built right into the enclosure to
capture that hazardous api directly
within the enclosure so that it can
prevent containment of any ductwork
or contamination of any duct work and
also be easily removed by a technician
if you were to use an api that is
hazardous in a fume hood you have the
entire exhaust pathway that would be
contaminated and difficult to
contaminate
and you're also risking ejection of
hazardous particulates out onto the top
of the building
and into the surrounding environment
unlike a chemical vapor from a you know
solvent
chemical powders do not dissipate and
disperse so they remain as equally
potent as they are in the laboratory
as they would outside the laboratory
another critical component of fume hoods
that is not helpful for most api
handling is that they typically run at
higher face velocities now over the last
several years fume hoods have become
much more effective at running safely at
lower phase velocities but
oftentimes ehms and organizations
choose to run them at 80 to 100 feet per
minute or sometimes even faster which
poses inherent risks
to both the process and to the safety of
the user and primarily the two
most common disruptions are to balance
stability primarily if you're working
with an open top loader balance
or also if you are working with a highly
potent api
that turbulent air can cause non-uniform
airflow through the face of the cabinet
or fume hood and as a result can cause
turbulence that would bring powders out
of the hood if airflow is too fast
so there are methods to establish what
type of
engineering control should be selected
and
fortunately a good reference is looking
at the oeb banding levels of any given
api
now these are again oedbs are
established by each organization
depending on their comfort level
and the the process and the oel of a
known
substance
and generally speaking
uh
containment for ventilated balance
enclosures that is of the highest levels
would be suitable for most activities
involving oeb one through four
compounds now oeb ones through three
very easily worked on in about
ventilated balance enclosure
obv4 should really be evaluated
carefully to assess the amount of energy
involved in the process to see if it
would exceed the containment abilities
of the balance enclosure
for compounds that are oed 4 or 5
typically an isolator is used
because they are sealed vessels that
promote a more robust containment that
can't be defeated by accidents or
inadvertent processes that happen while
handling apis
so in all of these factors again it's
important to look at not only the oeb
but
the the process that is happening with
that api and so you have to look at and
consider is the activity low or high
energy so to say
am i scooping a small volume of powder
just carefully as the gentleman and the
top image is doing or am i actively
grinding and using an automated
instrument that is going to create a lot
of aerosol
that is a higher energy and harder to
contain
also need to consider equipment space
requirements so if you are using um a
particle sizer or a large instrument
that's blocking a lot of the space
within an enclosure
it may mean that airflow is disrupted
through the the balance enclosure and as
a result you may need to either go to a
customized solution that is for that
instrument or you may need to consider a
fully sealed glove box that contains
just due to being sealed off from the
outside environment
another factor is again looking at
sample size so is it an analytical
process or are you handling bulk samples
that maybe require you know drum
manipulation devices to work safely both
not only for uh
for containment but also for
protection of the user from undue injury
during handling powders
and with that comes ergonomics and user
comfort because as jordan described
earlier those are factors that aren't
you know
directly addressed with a balance
enclosure or isolator but are inherently
there and promote
comfortable safe work that allows for
less accidents and easier manipulation
of powers without
spillage
the ventilated ballast enclosures
breaking them down a little bit more
closely you have typically a bench top
task specific configuration
usually meant for analytical weighing
or with some modifications can hold
mills tablet presses or any number of
instruments that would be used to
manipulate or assess apis
balance enclosures have
grown and changed over the years but
primarily today income including a hepa
filter that's integral to the system
along with a blower
and recirculate air back into the room
and in certain cases due to safety risk
or use of chemicals
additional chemical vapors may be
exhausted to the outside through a
thimble or canopy connection
or they may be redundant exhausted to a
second hepa filter before returning
either to the room or to the environment
during the use of a balance enclosure
um you should really be assessing the
types of work that are suitable for an
open environment
and um helping with containment of those
patterns that are going to be used you
know scooping out of containers and put
on the balances or smaller processes
helping those stay in the hood are
things like airfoils that allow for a
lower airflow velocity or face velocity
into the hood that promotes balanced
stability
but also helps you know other factors
that are important are a zoned rear
baffle that directs air all the way to
the back of the hood
and
in addition to this you really want to
make sure that you're using a design
that limits bash to bash contamination
so as mentioned earlier
ensuring that the hood is fully
cleanable that
important critical pieces like the
baffle can be brought down for full
cleaning as necessary
and as mentioned previously again these
are typically suitable for oeb one
through three and some processes of oed4
depending on how high energy or how
large the process is happening
as mentioned previously another key
factor is really focusing on on the
construction of these devices and while
simple hoods sitting on the bench top
they can play a key factor into the the
consistency of the products that you are
handling and
that includes making sure that you can
decontaminate the system so selecting an
enclosure that's made up of metal and
glass versus plastic will ensure that
the surfaces are easy to wipe and clean
and will last for a long time
again minimal seams help with a clear
wiping so if you look at the enclosure
pictures here you've got lots of spaces
that can be wiped easily
or removed and disassembled for a more
terminal clean as necessary
now there's also key factors in the
construction that promote easier
weighing uh glass is anti-static and
static dissipative and that helps
especially with lyophilized powders or
things that are harder to weigh just due
to staticky characteristics of the
powders
and you also want to look for something
that's vibration isolating because some
balances although many have quite
drastically improved over the years some
of the balances still start with
vibration
issues now uh
additionally in the hood you want to
being a safety product you want a way to
always manipulate and monitor the
airflow but setting the device to
measure when airflow goes too low and
notifying a user that's a key factor
that should be on every balance
enclosure
also you want some kind of device to
measure when the hepa filter is loaded
so typically a differential pressure
gauge of some sort is used more modern
systems are beginning to use blower
controls that assess the actual filter
loading and do so much more accurately
lastly you want to make sure that you've
got
flexibility for
characteristics that support work inside
the hood that's cord pass-throughs and
things like waste chutes to handle
excess consumable waste during any
processes
and lastly when you're working with
chemical solvents you also want to make
sure that your enclosure is compatible
with exhaust
right alongside your humans and other
products within your laboratory
in some instances processes exceed small
volumes and
typically in the kilo scale pilot scale
to other processes that go into
manufacturing you may wind up handling
barrels
of all different sizes and in these
processes
selecting a balance enclosure that's
designed to safely handle a barrel
is really important to make sure that
users are inadvertently
opening the barrel in an uncontained
uncontained environment so oftentimes
you see these in environments where qc
sampling is done or sometimes large
volumes are being dispensed from barrels
and
uh doing this in an integrated large
bold powder balance enclosure is going
to help contain that whole process
now many times people also seek out
downflow boosts to work with barrels
and while they can provide greater
accessibility to barrels by not having a
containment hood to work within
it also means that users are directly
exposed to the environment where the
weighing and manipulation processes are
happening happening and as a result have
to wear a lot more ppe and be mindful of
the processes that they're conducting so
it's always important to look at a risk
analysis
um you know is the barrel you know
suitable for a vbe or does it need to be
in a larger environment just based on
what's going to happen with the barrel
manipulation
and in many cases if you can keep it to
a hood it's going to ensure long-term
safety for users without the
burden of a large downflow installation
so as david mentioned previously that
vdes are going to be
pretty essential for carrying out oe
b level one through three um handling of
the hazardous powders uh and potentially
for some uh oeb level four hazardous
powders uh containment isolators are
gonna be your go-to piece of equipment
to handle oed level 4 and 5 hazardous
powders
again
containment isolators not only are
perfect for handling those extremely
potent apis but it's also a perfect
environment to contain a high energy
process like
grinding or me or milling
the reason why this is perfect is
because this actually presents itself as
a physical barrier between
an end user or a worker and whatever
process they're carrying out
generally these uh the containment
isolators have a class one leak rate per
iso 10648-2
and generally speaking the way these
pieces of equipment operate is that they
leverage a blower which generate
negative pressure which draws in room
air through a
inlet hepa or open filter
and then that blower then pushes that
air through an exhaust i'm sorry not an
exhaust but an outlet uh hepa or over
filter uh which then can then dump that
air back into that room or we can go
ahead and use a canopy or duct work
connection to exhaust that room to the
external environment
again just to reiterate like i said
before these containment isolators can
come either with heifer
uh or opal filtration and that's really
gonna provide up to an iso class 3
clean room standard
oftentimes again because these things
contain filters and we're trapping
hazardous particulates or pharmaceutical
apis
those filters are going to
need to be replaced periodically and uh
we can go ahead and provide an
additional level of protection or
engineering control of that bag and back
out system uh to protect uh
workers or people changing out those
filters from potential exposures to
those hazardous apis
um
when it comes to really kind of the
design characteristics of containment
isolators it is very task oriented we
have a
work surface that's contained so we can
do again those high energy processes so
milling and grinding of course
really kind of
what lends itself to that of the liner
construction so as david mentioned
previously that cleanability is a very
very important
component of uh
engineering control i'm a very
important component of uh contained
isolators and as far as engineering
controls uh oftentimes the stainless
steel liner in these have rolled corners
so again it makes it easier to clean any
residual powders from any weighing
grinding milling potential spillage that
happens inside the box
generally these
liners are 300 series stainless steel
but also
we do have the ability to
swap that out for a more chemically
resistant fiberglass liner
when it comes to the blower and doing
really any analytical or sensitive uh
weighing techniques it's important to
really isolate that blower to reduce
vibrations as much as much as possible
again vibration is just going to
add to inaccuracy when it comes to
weighing so it's very important to do
that
often times when you're placing pieces
of equipment in these enclosures
into these isolators
having the ability to add pass-throughs
and other ports is is paramount uh
supplying supplying uh electric
electricity to the units and then
getting information out of um
the enclosure um that's containing let's
just say an analytical balance
is important for
document tracking and record-keeping and
other quality assurance measures
again when it comes to leveraging these
containment isolators it cannot be
understated that the importance of uh
getting
the containment capabilities verified uh
by a third party is highly recommended
again trinity formerly known as state
bridge consultant can do that as a third
party
but
these uh
containment verification procedures can
be done in-house um
using leveraging those surrogate powder
testing so again sodium naproxen or
lactose
so we've reviewed the different types of
enclosures that can be selected to
handle different types of bands
and
it's a
critical to remember that when you're
selecting one of these enclosures for
laboratory or manufacturing process you
consider
more than just those data points that
suggest its potency level there's a lot
of factors that go into
ensuring that the process is safe and
that includes just evaluating not only
that potency but how the power is going
to be manipulated who's going to be
using it the processes involved uh
everything down to simply the ergonomics
of interacting with the powder can all
play a key
role in the user safety
so in all cases it's important to select
an enclosure that's robust and can be
validated either if that's from the
manufacturer itself or also done locally
on on site after installation and really
that is the
key gold standard of validating the
safety of a process is to replicate it
to a t
so in that sense that's a great
opportunity to get in touch with your
industrial hygienist on site or a
third-party industrial hygienist
utilize your ehs office for any and all
data to assess risks for yourself
and work with the equipment
manufacturers not only to
select you know the the office shelf
equipment but to look for solutions that
promote safety when using
more unique instruments and devices to
accomplish your unique tasks
so with that we're going to turn it over
to questions at this time and thank you
so much again for joining and we
hope to share a little bit of our
information with you as
the next question session begins
thank you david and jordan for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
does labconco provide any custom
designed options we have a requirement
to contain an instrument used with
powders
that's a great question
many times when you're looking at
products offered for powder containment
they can appear you know just like
standard
formats you know looking like standard
hoods or isolators
but if you have a unique process it's
definitely something that you want to
bring up during the equipment selection
phase
and uh if required uh the the designs of
some of our enclosures can definitely be
modified
whether that's you know an instrument
that needs to be housed inside like the
question is asking um you know and where
the ergonomic access point needs to be
within the hood that can be altered
or if you have you know pass-throughs or
other unique requirements that aren't on
the standard formats those are things
that are easily accommodated
through a little bit of design work on
our end
and definitely can influence and make
the process of using that enclosure
safer and more ergonomic
good question
great thank you
next question
can our fume hood be converted into a
powder containment hood with a hepa
filter
another good question um the answer is
it really depends um females are
traditionally designed to contain
chemical vapors
and so
um
they're going to be best
you know used for chemical processes not
so much api handling
without any kind of protection in the
ductwork like a hepa filter
the the hood is not a suitable choice
for api handling
in some cases sometimes hoods is they
they are containment devices
they can be retrofitted with a bag and
egg out hepa filter in the exhaust
pathway
it's usually less favorable though than
a true dedicated powder containment
enclosure like a vbe or an isolator
because
a portion of that ductwork is still
going to be contaminated by hazardous
apis
and furthermore that hood may not be
actually tested and known to be a good
containment device for powers so it's
always good to
check in with the manufacturer of that
product before using it for power
containment purposes
and it's possible and
proceeding with it as an api containment
vessel to use a bit of industrial
hygiene assessment first at a bare
minimum
thank you
next question
is there a good universal enclosure for
oeb4 and oeb5 apis
um yeah great question uh there sure is
so
the best universal enclosure for the
most part when handling oeb
four and five level apis is gonna be a
containment isolator while vbe can
handle some uh oeb level four apis um if
you want to be conservative when making
your assessment on what type of
enclosure i would always recommend
starting with the containment isolator
and that's really just because not only
does it provide a physical barrier or
separate industries from a workflow
it also
gives you a work area to do high energy
practices or workflows like
grinding and milling as well again
just to
add another level of protection uh when
it comes to separating
uh any inherent risk from handling these
um hazardous uh or potent compounds yeah
good question i might also add just
realizing there are some models that are
hybrid versions of a of a cbe and an
isolator
and while those
up front them look like great options
for flexible you know work between oeb 3
and 4 and 4 and 5 and 6 and above
you have to be really careful about the
parts that are used to you know that
pull in and out of that that conversion
between a box and a vbe
oftentimes it's difficult to fully
decontaminate the inside of an isolator
or it's just challenging for users to
see all powders and fully decontaminate
so while those are out there they have
to be really cautious about implementing
those
thank you
why is bag in bag out vital to
protecting workers from potential
hazardous exposure
well bag and bag out is just
so important because again when it comes
to changing out saturated filters so
either hepa or ulta we still need a
physical barrier um to not expose any um
not captured particulate matter in those
filters and so really especially with
any low-dose hazardous powders
you there's an inherent risk of
potential exposure when changing out
those so again
a physical barrier is key when it um
when discussing bag and back out uh and
again it's just another
safety measure engineering control uh
that's
commonplace and and a
requirement when it comes to protecting
workers handling hazardous powders or
pharmaceutical apis so good question
well it looks like that's all that we
have time for today thank you david and
jordan do you have any final comments
for our audience
at this time just thankful for all of
your time today and we look forward to
seeing you on a future webinar
absolutely i agree
great well thank you david and jordan
for your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor lab conco for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
you